like you know many other people I'm
watching what's going on in the United
States but I don't think it's right for
British politicians to give a running
commentary on a legal process in the
United States I think we have to leave
it to them and see we can talk about the
theater can't you I mean the fact that
you know he wasn't handcuffed why not he
wasn't mugshotted why not he was getting
preferential treatment well no these are
matters for for the judge who is in
charge of his court it's a different
legal system I can't claim I fully
understand it I know there are
similarities to ours but you know I I
think I need to resist the great
temptation to provide a running
commentary on what's happening with his
latest circus soils you're an absolute
spoil sport um how do you think your
boss would get on with him
well the you know kirst armor will get
on with whoever is elected president of
the United States because it's important
that the special relationship that
exists between the UK and the USA
continues whoever is in power we have to
respect the outcome of democratic system
whether we personally like it or not so
the right thing to do is to to work with
whoever the United States elects as
president okay um
out from ipsos
um saying that Sakia is neck and neck in
popularity with Rishi sunak it should be
Miles Ahead shouldn't it
well I've uh you know a polls a poll
I've been up and down the country this
week I've been in Swindon though sorry
you like them when they're in your favor
well of course you do if you're looking
at the polls at the moment Labor's had a
very consistent lead for a very long
time over the conservatives but we're
not going to be complacent About That
We're Not Gonna you know the polls don't
actually matter the only one that
matters is where people get out in the
general election and they mark their
crosses on a ballot paper and that is
what we're working for there are
elections this may on the 4th of may as
well where people be electing councils
up and down the country they'll take
their decisions and we'll see what they
have to say but yeah well I'm speaking
to voters I was in Plymouth yesterday
Swindon the day before they've had
enough of clowns and charlatans in
number 10 Downing Street and I think Kia
stama comes across as a very measured
sensible man who is talking about the
things that matter most to British
people the economy the National Health
Service and crime yeah are the CEO of
this polling company you know a very
reputable one ipsos says if secure
Windsor action it's likely he'll be the
least popular opposition leader to win a
majority in recent history he's on -20
for satisfaction that's where you're a
little bit I I have I you know I don't I
don't look at all the polls I know that
when I'm speaking to voters they think
kierstama would make a very credible
very sensible leader for this country
and they want a prime minister who will
deal with the problems they're actually
facing in the here and now you know
we've got seven million people wait on
the NHS waiting list under Rishi sunak
crime is running out of control in many
parts of the country people are looking
for a prime minister that will deal with
the things that matter to them and that
that is what kiss Dharma will offer as
we move towards the next general
election the problem it appears Shadow
secretary of state is that people don't
know what labor stands for you're not
getting your message across well part of
what I've been doing this week in in
traveling up and down the country and in
recent weeks is talking to people about
one thing that does matter to them a lot
and that's anti-social behavior and if
you're if you live in an area that's got
an awful lot of dump rubbish or gangs of
young people committing nuisance and
harassing uh local businesses it really
infuriates people that nothing is being
done about that there are no
consequences so one of the things
Labor's been talking about is how we can
put more police back on the streets and
rebuild neighborhood policing I'm sure
you've spoken to my colleague Yvette
Cooper who would be the Home Secretary
in a labor government uh in a labor
government and I've been talking about
what we would do to tackle dumped
rubbish and fly tipping which if you
live in an area that's got a lot of it
is really bothering you so Labor's
proposing to bring in cleanup squads
where those who are found to be dumping
rubbish will clear up that rubbish those
who make the mess will clear up the mess
and the British people consider that to
be a fair thing to do so whereas now
people get away with no consequences
with the labor government they will be
pleased to arrest you you and you will
pay the price for what you've done wrong
what is the one thing that you are going
to be campaigning on obviously I mean we
had we remember education education
education and other slogans what's the
one thing you're going to come well
let's wait until we get to the election
before we write the manifesto well and
you will do because when we get to that
election there will be a Manifesto and
it will be talking about the things that
matter most to the British people and
political parties never stick to their
manifestos oh actually the labor I think
it's very important that politicians do
try and stick to the pledges that
they're making well I think you have to
do what you you know the last Labor
government the last Labor government for
instance grew the economy
um 50 more every single year than the
current conservative government has done
if you're in the economy is it going to
be the NHS is it going to be education
what is it going to be well I think the
economy is always a top issue when it
comes to an election and many of the
problems we're facing in this country
right now cost of living crisis is
because the government's lost control of
the economy they've failed to grow the
economy we've had the worst decade for
wage growth since the Great Depression
the 1930s now we've got runaway
inflation people are feeling feeling
worse off than ever before yeah but you
know what's going to happen growing the
economy is how you tackle them a lot
money at people in the budget and then
they're going to call an election and
when it comes to it people think oh I've
just got a load of money from the
government maybe I'll put my ex there
the the conservatives do like to treat
people for Falls but people remember
what happened last October when we had
that disastrous mini budget from Liz
truss and quasi-quartering that caused
quote that caused a run on the pound it
caused an increase in price Rises people
are still paying a mortgage premium you
know if you're if you're if you're if
your mortgages come to an end and you're
having to remortgage now you're paying
on average 2 000 pounds more than you
would have been doing before the mini
budget because of what they did it it's
still there and people remember it talk
to me about tick tock
I'll tell you what I want to know are
you on Tick Tock I'm not no no me
neither I don't understand why people
are um should it be banned
I think you know with all of these
platforms it's a matter of regulating
them properly so they're safe for people
to use and one of the things that I I
called on the news yesterday is Tick
Tock are failing to stop young people
going on their own access
they shouldn't well and right and
rightly so so I think what you need is
proper regulation and then penalties for
where they fail but I mean many parents
will be very worried about what children
particularly young children can access
online because many parents you know you
and I just said we're not on Tick Tock
adults don't all understand these
platforms but the kids are on there
unsupervised spaces where people who
intend harm to children can go and
access them it's very important there's
strong robust regulation to keep kids
safe and that's something that you would
look at if you were in government I
think it's essential if kids are at risk
then of course government must make sure
we keep those safe spaces safe